if you're considering getting white
seats in your brand new Tesla but you're
concerned about keeping them clean well
it's actually very simple to do so first
things first what you want to do is go
out and buy yourself some leather Shield
the leather Shield is very simple to
apply anybody can do it you basically
just spread this over all of the seats
and all of the white leather next what
you're going to need to do is basically
get some baby wipes and clean them over
every single week the baby wipes have to
be 100 pure water and no chemicals
inside them so they're just natural baby
wipes and in the worst case scenario if
something really does stain you can try
using some pure Castile soap that is
going to help you clean any of those
extra tough stains off